[Música]
y continuamos con las noticias
económicas aquí en directo América y lo
hacemos en Estados Unidos porque hay
noticias del techo de deuda que tendrían
problemas para cumplirlo o no Daniela
Así es María Clara Pues el departamento
del tesoro se podría quedar sin
capacidad para pagar sus deudas en algún
momento entre julio y septiembre esto
sucede cuando los gastos del ejecutivo
son mayores a sus ingresos y se ocurre
un déficit la situación la explica mejor
el director de presupuesto del congreso
el límite de la deuda de 31.4 billones
de dólares se alcanzó el 19 de enero de
este año el tesoro comenzó a tomar las
llamadas medidas extraordinarias para
pedir prestado fondos adicionales
proyectamos que si el límite de la deuda
permanece sin cambios la capacidad del
gobierno para endeudarse se agotará
entre julio y septiembre de 2023
ahora María Clara si Estados Unidos no
quiere entrar en incumplimientos lo que
también se conoce como default debería o
Elevar o suspender ese límite de deuda
actual y ahí es donde entra en escena al
congreso que debe aprobarlo pero los
republicanos que controlan la cámara de
representantes se niegan porque dicen
que lo que debe hacer el gobierno es
apretarse el cinturón en lugar de seguir
gastando el gobierno de todas maneras
tiene otro as bajo la manga que son los
impuestos ya que entre abril y mayo se
sabrá cuánto pueden recaudar Y eso puede
empeorar o aliviar la situación
dependiendo de Cuánta plata tienen los
estadounidenses una difícil situación
entonces enfrente del presidente
y no es el único mandatario en nuestro
continente que está enfrentando
tensiones porque hay un nuevo choque por
materias económicas entre México y Perú
pues es la presidenta peruana Dina
boluarte ha criticado a su homólogo
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador por
apoyar al destituido Pedro castillo y
conceder asilo a su esposa y a sus hijos
ahora lo acusa de no entregarle a Lima
la presidencia pro tempore de la alianza
del Pacífico un traspaso que estaba
programado para noviembre del año pasado
simplemente por seguir apoyando al
expresidente que dio el golpe y además
que tiene carpetas Fiscales y ahí están
en investigación no nos quiere entregar
la presidencia pro tempore de la alianza
del Pacífico También queremos decirle al
presidente amlo de que un tema político
es un tema político pero un tema del
desarrollo de los pueblos a través de
las alianzas como en esta la alianza del
Pacífico es tan importante para el
desarrollo de nuestros pueblos
Daniela y cuéntanos Por qué es tan
importante esta Alianza del Pacífico que
está en el centro de las tensiones Claro
porque aglomera a más de 230 millones de
personas es una alianza que constituye
la octava economía más grande del mundo
y representa el 41% del producto interno
bruto de América Latina y el Caribe Hoy
está conformada por Chile Colombia
México y Perú y su principal Pilar es
que permite la libre circulación de
bienes de servicios capitales y también
de personas y de América pasamos a medio
oriente porque el Líbano están quemando
bancos Por qué claro pues lo están
quemando por la misma razón de siempre
María Clara y es que los bancos desde
2019 han venido restringiendo
unilateralmente los retiros de Divisas y
libras libanesas porque se quedaron sin
liquidez eso ha hecho que muchos hayan
tratado de recuperar su dinero incluso
por la fuerza hemos visto imágenes de
personas tomándose los bancos hay un
grupo de presión también que representa
estos depositantes con dinero atascado
llamado depósitos out Cry y la libra
libanesa también sigue marcando mínimos
históricos hoy el dólar en el mercado
informal vale 80.000 libras libanesas
esto es cinco veces más de lo que cuesta
en el mercado oficial
que están esperando ustedes libaneses
para bajar y quitarle sus derechos a
esta mafia de ladrones y criminales que
está gobernando dónde están los Derechos
Humanos no hay electricidad ni agua nada
de nada en este país cuál no sienten a
la gente nos ven como ovejas no nos
quedaremos callados sobre el valor de
nuestra vida
Entonces como quien dice no pueden
retirar su dinero del banco europeo su
propio dinero movámonos entonces Cuáles
son las noticias bursátiles de hoy bueno
primero que todo una comisión del
gobierno ruso aprobó la venta del
fabricante de muebles sueco a IKEA en
Rusia a dos compradores locales también
airbags El fabricante de aviones más
grande del mundo subió sus ganancias en
16% en 2022 hasta 6 mil millones de
dólares Aunque reconoció que no cumplió
la meta de producción y finalmente la
juguetería hasbro pronóstico para este
año ganancias anuales por debajo de las
estimaciones de Wall Street golpeada por
una fuerte caída en la demanda a medida
que los clientes Pues están dejando de
comprar juguetes porque los precios
están muy altos y no es tiempo de
comprar juguetes mejor comida así
entonces la inflación afecta hasta los
juguetes Así es hasta los niños hasta
los niños Gracias Daniela por las
noticias económicas nos vemos mañana nos
vemos mañana y nosotros seguimos con más
en directo América